er macht es tatsächlich ihnen macht
baut die größte batterie waren der
welt und löst damit die
stromversorgungs probleme in
südaustralien angefangen hat es mit
einer wette die jetzt gilt in 100 tagen
will macht die batterie farm aus dem
boden stampfen kann das funktionieren
klicks zum ziel kommen
das ist wirklich verrückt ihnen mag
krempelt echt die welt um wo andere
unternehmen wochen monate und jahre
brauchen um zu planen projektieren
angebote einholen und beweise legte
einfach los die industriebosse weltweit
kommen aus dem staunen nicht mehr heraus
und scheinen dem feld mit milliardär
und seinen erfolgen verständnislos zu
folgen
das scheint alle herausforderungen wie
ein startup anzugehen selbst die akkus
mit spacex hat er mal im vorbeigehen
einen raumfahrtunternehmen gewonnen es
hat bereits die raumfahrt revolutioniert
und durch die wiederverwendbarkeit der
ersten stufe der felten rakete und der
dragon café die kosten deutlich gesenkt
die raumfahrt ist so in der lage ihm
wirklich neue dimensionen vor zu bringen
seine versprechen scheinen dabei
verrückt aber er kann sie einhalten
wenn wir wirklich absolut faszinierend
um es mal mit spock aus star trek zu
sagen
auch bei dem elektroautohersteller tesla
kann was wohl alle seine versprechen
einhalten haben die aktionäre zweifeln
am erfolgskurs aber die produktion des
modells drei startet planmäßig am 9
juli auf diesem modell baut die zukunft
des autoherstellers der 2016 84.000
teslas produzierte mit modell 3 wird
tesla zum massenhersteller für den
wagen sollen rund 400.000 bestellungen
vorliegen das wirklich ein bisschen
verrückt aus dem nichts zum führenden
elektroauto hersteller der welt und
damit zu einer wirklich ernstzunehmende
konkurrenz für die alteingesessenen
autohersteller mit dem modell 3 könnte
das realität werden und jetzt die
weltgrößte batterie formal ebenso in
100 tagen wie bitte am 10 märz hatte
marc getwittert dass tesla die
energieprobleme des bundesstaates
südaustralien in 100 tagen lösen
könne
südaustralien leidet darunter dass
immer mehr kohlekraftwerke abgeschaltet
wurden und windpark von gaskraftwerke
jetzt nicht in der lage ausreichend
strom zu produzieren
immer wieder kommt es dort zu
stromausfällen ein systembedingt das
problem regenerativer energien egal ob
solarzellen oder windkraftwerke der
strom steht nicht dauerhaft zur
verfügung innenmaß lösung für dieses
problem ein netzwerk aus batterien er
will die energieversorgung
revolutionieren dazu
solar sagt siegl und die power batterien
und batterie formen seine vision ein
netzwerk mit batterien in wohnungen und
häusern und batterie farm und die
stromerzeugung aus der sonne mit tesla
solar ziehen und für die tesla
elektroautos wird so preiswert und
umweltfreundlich strom erzeugt und
erscheint dazu tatsächlich relativ
problemlos in der lage zu sein ein wenig
erinnert das ganze an die einführung
des iphones nur in einem anderen
maßstab die branchengrößen haben
damals gelacht viele von ihnen gibt es
heute nicht mehr
mal sehen was so auf dem strom und
automarkt passiert für die batterie
farm in australien geht macht jetzt eine
riesen wetter ein er will sie fahren in
100 tagen bauen dabei wird sie eine
kapazität von 100 megawatt haben wissen
der lage 30.000 häuser gleichzeitig mit
strom zu versorgen und max ist sie damit
dreimal stärker als jede bisher auf der
welt gebaute batterie farm in
kalifornien hatte tesla bereits einer
farm auf batterien anfang 2017
fertiggestellt da man braucht ist
häßler 90 tage für 20 megawatt wir
können also sehr gespannt sein was
jetzt noch alles passieren wird für den
klimawandel findet auf jeden fall gute
nachrichten ich hoffe dass es auch so
bleibt mehr über ihren mars gibt es
hier mit tempo 200 unterirdisch durch
die stadt
da revolutioniert macht den
innerstädtischen verkehr wirklich
ziemlich irre seine pläne einfach
draufklicken und wenn er nichts mehr
über markt neueste pläne verpassen
wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht dass die glocke
dann verpasst ihr kein video bis dann
bleibt dran